pet owners across the country are being
warned about the potentially deadly
algae three dogs in North Carolina died
last week after swimming in a pond that
had blooms of blue-green algae CTM
consumer investigative correspondent and
a winner is here with the dangers of
this growing threat Anna yeah good
morning the blooms of this harmful algae
are widespread and they've been shutting
down beaches and lakes across the Gulf
Coast this summer
health effects can range from skin
rations to organ failure a threat many
pet owners don't know about until it's
too late
Abbey Izzy and Harpo meant the world to
their owners Denis Mintz and Melissa
Martin but after taking their dogs to
play at a Wilmington North Carolina pond
the joy shattered in just minutes Denis
brought the two little dogs upstairs to
get their back next and um she started
yelling for me that something was wrong
with Abby one of the Westies the dog
started to have seizures they rushed
them to the vet less than five hours
later all three dogs were dead as the
trees the animals were poisoned by
something lurking in the water a
microscopic bacteria called blue-green
algae it mostly infest waters when the
weather is warm and releases toxins that
can cause liver damage respiratory
paralysis and organ failure among other
deadly conditions in recent weeks
several dogs have been poisoned across
the south this Australian Shepherd named
FINA died less than an hour after
ingesting toxic algae in the Guadalupe
River outside Austin and Marietta
Georgia this border collie Aria suffered
the same heartbreaking fate no your pets
and you know when something's not right
I just didn't think it was this correct
some of this is almost invisible right
Ana so what do you look out for if
you're a dog owner you know the
blue-green algae they say can sometimes
range from brown to red in color it can
have an odor
now they say to protect yourself and
your pets you should avoid
of water that looked discolored and have
foam or scum on the surface if your pet
has been exposed rinse them with tap
water as soon as possible take them to
the vet immediately but you know in some
of these stories they've said that it
takes less than an hour
it's so painful dogs a pet dog under any
circumstances it's certainly doing
something that they love doing thank you
Anna